>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
REMEMBER WHEN POLITICAL DEBATES
WERE THE HIGHLIGHT OF THE
POLITICAL YEAR?
LIKE BOXING MATCHES, EVERYONE
WOULD WATCH THEM.
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN ANYMORE.
DURING THE LAST PRESIDENTIAL
DEBATES WERE TERRIBLE AND
THERE'S A REASON FOR THAT, THEYE
BORING.
EVERYTHING IS SCRIPTED, YOU KNOW
WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO SAY
BEFORE THEY SAY IT'S PEER BUT IF
YOU KEEP WATCHING THE LOWER TIEN
THE FIGHT CARD, SOMETIMES YOU
SEE SOMETHING INTERESTING.
IT HAPPENS INVARIABLY BY
ACCIDENT BUT IT REVEALS A LOT
ABOUT THE COUNTRY AND THE PEOPLE
TRYING TO LEAD IT.
THAT JUST HAPPENED LAST MONTH IN
VIRGINIA DURING A GOVERNORS
DEBATE.
THE GOVERNOR OF VIRGINIA,
GRAVELY DAMAGED THE STATE.
HE IS A CLEAR CLINTON OPERATIVE,
YOU MAY REMEMBER DURING HIS MANY
BRUSHES WITH THE PARENT
INDICTMENT.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" WAS ALWAYS
TELLING YOU HE'S ABOUT TO GET
INDICTED, HE NEVER WAS.
INSTEAD HE RAN VIRGINIA INTO THE
GROUND AND HE WANTS TO HURT IT
EVEN MORE AND BE REELECTED.
AS OF LAST MONTH,
TERRY McAULIFFE ANNOUNCED, IT
WELLED UP WITHIN HIM AND HE TOLD
US THAT PARENTS NO LONGER HAVE A
SAY IN THEIR OWN CHILDREN'S
EDUCATION, THE ONE THAT THEY PAY
FOR.
INSTEAD, TERRY McAULIFFE
INFORMED THE STATE OF VIRGINIA
THE GOVERNOR IS IN CHARGE OF
EDUCATION PERIOD.
>> I GET REALLY TIRED OF
EVERYONE RUNNING DOWN TEACHERS.
I LOVE OUR TEACHERS AND WHAT
THEY HAVE DONE THROUGH COVID,
THESE ARE REAL HEROES WHO
DESERVE OUR RESPECT.
>> Tucker: HE'S A DEMAGOGUE
BUT IGNORE THE SECOND PART OF
THE SENTENCE, I DON'T THINK
PARENTS HAVE ANY RIGHT TELLING
TEACHERS WHAT TO TEACH, REALLY?
SO PARENTS DON'T HAVE A RIGHT TO
CONTROL THEIR OWN KIDS?
YOU'VE A RIGHT TO TELL THE
PEDIATRICIAN WHAT KIND OF
MEDICAL TREATMENT YOUR KIDS GET?
NO.
THIS IS THE NEW RULE, THE
GOVERNMENT MAKES ALL KEY
DECISIONS ABOUT YOUR CHILDREN.
IT'S NOT JUST TRUE IN VIRGINIA,
IT IS ORTHODOXY THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
AS OF YESTERDAY, THIS IDEA
UNPRECEDENTED IN THE HISTORY OF
AMERICA HAS THE FULL BACKING OF
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
IN THE OTHER WORDS, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
IF YOU ARE ONE OF THE
TROGLODYTES WHO BELIEVE YOU HAVE
SOME SAY IN WHAT YOUR CHILDREN
ARE TAUGHT IN THE SCHOOL YOU PAY
FOR, THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
NOW VIEWS YOU AS A DOMESTIC
TERRORIST AND THEY WILL COMPEL
YOU TO SHUT UP.
THE BIKE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
HAS MADE THE VERY CLEAR.
MERRICK GARLAND, THE MODERATE
SOFT-SPOKEN ONE WHO TURNED OUT
NOT TO BE MONGREL AT ALL BUT A
CRAZY PERSON AND IS NOW THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL CUSTOMER HE
ISSUED A MEMORANDUM YESTERDAY,
AND ON THE FBI TO CRACK DOWN
ON PARENTS WHO COMPLAIN ABOUT TL
BOARD.
KEEP IN MIND, AT THIS EXACT
MOMENT HE WROTE THAT WE LEARNED
THAT MURDERS IN THE
UNITED STATES THE ADVENT OF
BLACK LIVES MATTER HAVE GONE UP
38%.
THOUSANDS MORE DEAD PEOPLE.
THIS IS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL,
OUR CHIEF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER.
HE DID NOT ISSUE A MEMO ABOUT
THAT.
HE ISSUED A MEMO ABOUT PEOPLE
COMMITTING WRONG THING.
GARLAND -- FOR ADDRESSING THIS
DISTURBING TREND.
THE DISTURBING TREND BEING
PARENTS COMPLAINING.
IN THE COMING DAYS, GARLAND
ROAD, THE DEPARTMENT WILL
ANNOUNCE A SERIES OF MEASURES
DESIGNED TO ADDRESS THE RISE IN
CRIMINAL CONDUCT DIRECTED
TOWARDS A SCHOOL PERSONNEL.
CRIMINAL CONDUCT, WHAT DOES THAT
CONSIST OF?
BOMBINGS?
ASSAULT?
NO, COMPLAINING.
IT IS NO CRIMINAL TO DISAGREE
WITH YOUR KID'S SCHOOL.
WHAT IF WE LEARN FROM THIS?
AMONG OTHER THINGS WE HAVE
LEARNED THE BY ADMINISTRATION NO
LONGER BELIEVES IN THE MOST
BASIC PRECEPTS OF LIBERAL
DEMOCRACY, AMONG THEM YOUR
FREEDOM OF SPEECH SHOULD NEVER
BE BRIDGED, THE GOVERNMENT MUST
CONVINCE YOU NOT COMPEL YOU,
ALMOST ALWAYS.
AND YOU AND NOT THE GOVERNMENT
IS IN CHARGE OF YOUR CHILDREN.
MERRICK GARLAND DID NOT GIVE
BIRTH TO YOUR KIDS.
THEY ARE YOURS, NOT HIS.
BUT THEY DON'T ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
ANYMORE.
SO THEY ARE HAPPY TO USE ARMED
AGENTS OF THE STATE TO ENFORCE
THEIR IDEOLOGY, AND THEY HAVE
TO, BECAUSE THAT IDEOLOGY IS
DEEPLY UNPOPULAR WITH MOST
AMERICANS.
NOW, WHY DID THE DOJ ISSUE THIS
LETTER?
BECAUSE THEY RECEIVED A
COMPLAINT FROM THE NATIONAL
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION, HUGE
DONORS, OF COURSE, TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN THE
COMPLAINT CITED CITIZENS WHO
WERE UPSET OVER THE TEACHINGS OF
"CRITICAL RACE THEORY AND
MASKING OF CHILDREN," WHICH IS
MEDICALLY UNNECESSARY.
THE GROUP WROTE TO THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND SAID SOME OF
THE ACTIONS AGAINST THE SCHOOL
BOARD "COULD BE THE EQUIVALENT
TO A FORM OF DOMESTIC TERRORISM
AND HATE CRIMES."
OH, SO SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS ARE
NOW A PROTECTED GROUP.
IF YOU DISAGREE WITH THEM YOU'RE
COMMITTING A HATE CRIME, NOT
VOICING AN OPINION, WHICH IS
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED.
NO, IT'S AN ACT OF VIOLENCE TO
DISAGREE WITH THEM, LET'S GET
SPECIFIC.
ACCORDING TO NATIONAL SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION IT IS THINGS
LIKE THIS, "EARLIER THIS MONTH A
STUDENT IN TENNESSEE WAS MOCKED
DURING A BOARD MEETING FOR
ADVOCATING MASKS AND SCHOOLS
AFTER TESTIFYING TO HIS
GRANDMOTHER, WHO WAS AN
EDUCATOR, DIED BECAUSE OF
COVID-19.
THE ASSOCIATION WENT ON TO SAY
THAT THE FED SHOULD USE "THE
PATRIOT ACT CREATED AFTER 9/11,
TO THE REGRET OF MOST THINKING
PEOPLE, AND THAT POSTAL
INSPECTORS SHOULD PROBE THE
"CYBERBULLYING" SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS SAY THEY HAVE FACED.
WHERE DOES THIS LEAVE US?
IT'S SIMPLE, MOCKING SOMEONE WHO
CALLS FOR MEDICALLY UNNECESSARY
MASK MANDATES IS NOW DOMESTIC
TERRORISM AND A CHIEF CONCERN OF
THE FBI.
WHAT YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO DO
GOING FORWARD BECAUSE IT IS A
HATE CRIME IS POINT OUT THAT
CHILDREN AND TEENS ACTUALLY
AREN'T DYING FROM COVID.
THEY ARE DYING FROM A LOT OF
THINGS BUT NOT FROM COVID.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS CHART, WE
ARE GOING TO PUT IT ON THE
SCREEN AND IT TELLS YOU
EVERYTHING.
IT TELLS YOU A LOT OF KIDS ARE
DYING OF A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS.
DROWNING, AS ALWAYS, IS AT THE
TOP OF THE LIST.
CAR CRASHES TOO.
BUT NOTICE MORE KIDS ARE DYING
FROM SUICIDE, IN SOME CASES
DIRECTLY RELATED TO THESE
POLICIES, THAN ARE DYING FROM
COVID.
SO THAT IS A NATIONAL CRISIS.
IT IS COMPLETELY UNADDRESSED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OR
ANYONE ELSE IN OUR GOVERNMENT.
ALL THAT IS ADDRESSED IS THE
IDEOLOGICAL CLIENTS, PEOPLE
DISAGREEING.
FOR LONG TIME SCHOOL BOARDS HAVE
TRIED TO SHUT UP ANYONE WHO
CHALLENGES THEIR ORTHODOXY ON
COVID OR ANYTHING ELSE.
IN MAY IN THE KELLY VIRGINIA,
THE NEWLY LIBERAL, THE SCHOOL
BOARD USED A MASK MANDATES TO
SILENCE PARENT WHO CLAIMED THEY
WERE INDOCTRINATING HIS CHILD.
>> I'M GOING TO READ AN EXPERT
FROM A FRESHMAN HONORS ENGLISH
CLASS, SHE IS A -- JUST LIKE HER
SISTER.
BELIEVE EVERY DUDE ON THE
COURSE.
IT'S TIME FOR LPS TO GET THEIR
ACT IN ORDER.
THE CURTAINS AND PULLED BACK AND
PEOPLE CAN NOW SEE THE DEFICIENT
LEADERSHIP IN THIS COUNTY.
MY 5-YEAR-OLD IS BEING PEDDLED
TRANSGENDER BOOKS IN HER
LIBRARY, TEENAGERS ARE BEING
SERVED PORNOGRAPHY UNDER THE
GUISE OF YOUNG ADULT READING.
DO SOMETHING, BE A LEADER
BECAUSE THE CITIZENS --
>> PLEASE COVER YOUR NOSE WITH
YOUR MASK.
SPEAK UNVACCINATED, GIVE ME TEN
SECONDS BACK.
>> YOU KNOW THE RULES,
THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: IT'S UNBELIEVABLE,
SO THEY CUT HIS MICROPHONE.
YOU'RE VIOLATING COVID LAW.
THEY DON'T WANT TO HEAR HIM HEAR
THAT AS A PARENT WHO'S PAYING
FOR THE SCHOOL WHOSE 5-YEAR-OLD
IS IN THE CARE OF THESE
LUNATICS.
SO THEY JUST CUT HIS MICROPHONE.
NOW THEY UP THE ANTE.
THEY CAN THROW YOU IN JAIL IF
YOU POINT OUT THAT WHAT THEY ARE
DOING IS HURTING YOUR CHILDREN.
BY THAT STANDARD, WE ARE IN
TROUBLE.
A WHOLE LOT MORE CONDUCT IS
ABOUT TO BECOME CRIMINAL IN THE
EYES OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
REMEMBER ALL THOSE PARENTS FROM
SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS THIS
SUMMER CUSTOMER AND PRESUMABLY
MERRICK GARLAND IS GOING TO
INVESTIGATE THEM TOO.
>> IN MARCH MY CHILD HAD TO
WATCH A TED TALK IN ENGLISH
CLASS NOT ANYTHING RELATED TO
ENGLISH BUT RATHER OPPRESSION
AND ACKNOWLEDGING PRIVILEGE.
ANY PARENT WITH A PULSE KNOWS
THAT THIS IS WRONG.
WHY HAS PUBLIC SCHOOLS, SO MIRED
IN EXTREMIST POLITICS AND A
PERMISSIVE CULTURE THAT SEEMS TO
CELEBRATE THE LATEST POPULAR
FADS LIKE GENDER FLUIDITY.
WE OPPOSE YOUR EFFORTS TO
IMPOSE CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
AN OVERTLY RACIST DOCTRINE THAT
TEACHES OUR CHILDREN TO JUDGE
AND CATEGORIZE OTHERS BASED
SOLELY ON THE COLOR OF THEIR
SKIN.
>> THEIR JOB IS TO TEACH OUR
KIDS MATH, SCIENCE, BIOLOGY,
LITERATURE AND THAT'S IT.
NOT IDEOLOGY.
>> I BELIEVE LIKE ALL OF YOU
THAT YOU HAVE DONE A REALLY BAD
JOB AND MAYBE IT'S A GOOD TIME
TO CHANGE SOMETHING.
MAYBE START RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: A LOT OF THOSE, YOU
MAY NOTICED, FOR IMMIGRANT
PARENTS BECAUSE OF OUR FAMILY
SLEEVE GOOD EDUCATION SYSTEM
ONLY TO FIND OUT THAT IS A LIE.
IT IS THE WORST.
A LOT OF PARENTS, AUNTS IS GOING
TO BE SIMPLE, PULL AWAY, LEAVE,
HOMESCHOOL, START YOUR OWN
SCHOOL.
PARENTS WON'T PUT UP WITH US,
THEIR CHILDREN ARE BEING HURT BY
IT.
ON THE OTHER HAND YOU'VE GOT TO
ASK YOURSELF WHY LET THE
LUNATICS TAKE CONTROL OF THE
SYSTEM THEY DIDN'T BUILD?
IT'S NOT THERE IS, THEY DON'T
GET TO WRECKAGE.
MAYBE WE SHOULD STAY AND FIGHT
AND TAKE BACK THE SCHOOLS WHICH
BELONG TO US HERE THEY ARE OURS,
THEY DON'T BELONG TO THE
TEACHERS UNION OR SCHOOL BOARDS,
MUCH LESS MERRICK GARLAND,
WHOEVER THAT IS.
THEY BELONG TO US, AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
THE BACKDROP TO ALL OF THIS ARE
THE PEOPLE YOU JUST SAW I
DESIGNATED AS CRIMINALS BY THE
BITE ADMINISTRATION, THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, SO-CALLED
PEERED AT THE VERY SAME TIME,
ACTUAL CRIMINALITY, ACTUAL
VIOLENCE AND MURDERS, NOT
METAPHORICAL VIOLENCE, HATE
CRIMES, THE REAL VIOLENCE,
PEOPLE SHOOTING THEMSELVES, AND
I, IS RISING FASTER THAN IT HAS
IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
WHAT IS THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
DOING ABOUT THIS?
NOTHING.
BECAUSE A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE
HAVE THEIR VOTERS, POLITICAL
ALLIES.
SPEAKING POLITICAL ALLIES, THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS NO
PROBLEM ON THEIR POLITICAL
ALLIES TERRORIZED SITTING U.S.
SENATORS AND BATHROOMS
>> WE KNOCK ON DOORS FOR YOU TO
GET YOU ELECTED AND JUST HOW WE
GET YOU WOULD LIKE THAT WE
CAN GET YOU OUT OF OFFICE IF
YOU DON'T SUPPORT WHAT YOU
PROMISED US.
>> -- HUMAN TRAFFICKING --
ECONOMIES.
I NEED YOU TO STAND BY WORKERS,
LOTS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE LIKE
ME --
>> Tucker: IT IS NOT NORMAL TO
HARASS SOMEONE IN THE LADIES
ROOM, PERIOD.
IT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE.
JOE BIDEN HAS NO PROBLEM WITH
THAT, HE SAID THAT YESTERDAY.
WHAT USED TO HAVE A BIG PROBLEM
WITH THAT.
THIS IS THE PATH TO CHAOS AND
VIOLENCE BUT THE DOJ HAS NO
PROBLEM WITH THAT WHATSOEVER.
THEY HAVE A PROBLEM WITH YOU,
THE PERSON WHO PAYS TAXES AND
SENDS THEIR KID TO PUBLIC
SCHOOL.
IT'S NOT A PROBLEM AT ALL APPEAR
THE PROBLEM IS YOU COMPLAINING
ABOUT IT.
AND IF YOU DO THE DOJ WILL
TARGET YOU LIKE A DOMESTIC
TERRORIST USING THE PATRIOT ACT.
YET IF YOU COME TO THIS COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY LIKE THE WOMAN YOU
JUST TAKING THE VIDEO AND THE
LADIES ROOM AND HARASSING THE
UNITED STATES SENATOR IN THE
BATHROOM FOR NONVOTING THE WAY
YOU THINK SHE SHOULD, YOU FACE
NO CONSEQUENCES AT ALL.
BY THE WAY, IT IS NOT JUST
ILLEGAL ALIENS TO GET A PASS ON
THIS STUFF.
ACTUAL CRIMES BEING IGNORED,
YEAH, IT IS COME AT SCALE.
ONE EXAMPLE, PROSECUTORS IN
CHICAGO
REJECTED -- SENT OTHERS
TO THE HOSPITAL BUT NO BIG DEAL
BECAUSE PROSECUTORS IN CHICAGO
SAID THEY WERE "MUTUAL
COMPETITORS."
GANG MEMBERS SHOOTING EACH OTHER
ARE NOT REALLY OUR CONCERN.
THE GUY DIED.
LAST WEEK, PROSECUTORS IN
CHICAGO ANNOUNCED THEY WOULDN'T
PURSUE MURDER CHARGES BECAUSE A
TEENAGER WHO WAS STABBED TO
DEATH WAS ENGAGING AND THEY SAID
"MUTUAL COMBAT."
AGAIN, TOTALLY FINE.
SOME KID GETS STABBED TO DEATH,
NOT A BIG DEAL.
THAT IS NOTHING LIKE DISAGREEING
WITH THE SCHOOL BOARD.
ON SOME LEVEL IT IS NOT.
GANG MEMBERS CAN TREAT EACH
OTHER, THEY CAN STABBED CHILDREN
TO